tous les jours sans faire attention que
tout en dépend c'est l'unité de mesure
de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
près de
270 mille cas de co vide en france un
chiffre alors que les débats ont repris
ce soir à l'assemblée autour du projet
de loi sur le pacs vaccinale après avoir
été suspendu cette nuit un contretemps
pour le calendrier n'exécute yves qui
espère toujours mettre en place ce
projet le 15 janvier prochain tout à
l'heure à l'assemblée jean castex a
évoqué un coût politique pour freiner le
débat l'opposition parle elle
d'amateurisme
[Musique]
aux etats unis aussi le variant mikron
continue sa progression de manière
inquiétante record battu
outre-atlantique avec plus d'un million
de cartes kovy de recenser ces dernières
24 heures pour tenter de venir à bout de
l'épidémie l'administration maiden
décide aujourd'hui de doubler sa
commande du traitement anti copie du
laboratoire pfizer aujourd'hui 62 % de
la population américaine est
complètement vaccinés contre le coc vie
et puis au soudan lors de nouvelles
manifestations contre le pouvoir
militaire deux jours après la démission
du premier ministre est d'emilie
personnes se sont retrouvées dans la
capitale khartoum et les forces de
l'ordre ont tenté de disperser la foule
à coups de gaz lacrymogène pour
l'instant pas de chiffres communiqués
par des autorités sur d'éventuelles
victimes
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
si vous nous rejoignez sur rt france
la reprise cet après-midi du débat sur
le pass vaccinale à l'assemblée cette
nuit il avait été suspendu à la surprise
générale après qu'une majorité d'élus
ont voté contre la poursuite des débats
un revers pour le gouvernement qui
souhaite toujours mettre en place à son
projet pour le 15 janvier prochain le
calendrier initial pourrait donc être
modifié et contrecarrer les plans de la
majorité les détails avec notre reporter
david kelly femmes les discussions
reprennent à 23h pas de nuit blanche en
perspective en revanche pour les aides
députés puisque à 3 heures du matin les
débats doivent cesser c'est ce qu'ont
décidé en tout cas les présidents de
groupe de l'assemblée nationale il est
donc possible que les discussions se
poursuivent demain après midi à 15
heures ce qui forcément parasite le
calendrier d'adoption rapide qui avait
fixé l'exécutif pour ce projet de loi
sur le pass vaccinale d'où ce contexte
de tension palpable au sein de
l'hémicycle 1 durant cette journée le
premier ministre a poussé un coup de
gueule jean castex dénonce une forme
d'irresponsabilité de la part de
l'opposition qui a obtenu hier soir la
suspension de l'examen du projet de loi
sur le pass 1 vaccinale un élan de
colère à ceyrat regardé hier
272 de nos concitoyens sont morts du
fait de la maladie portant le nombre de
décès depuis son déclenchement à 124
1247 et pendant ce temps là je le dis me
tournant vers certes partie de
l'hémicycle
certains s'ingénient à faire des coups
politiques
offrez des le débat
je vous le dis je vous le dis ce n'est
pas responsable
ce n'est pas responsable
oui madame la présidente pour le coup
vous avez raison nous sommes engagés
dans une course contre la montre avec le
virus le virus galope et vous tirez sur
la mer
près de 515 amendements doivent encore
être examinées en profond désaccord avec
ce pass vaccinale a dit différents
groupes politiques de l'opposition se
sont félicités de cette victoire en la
démocratie déclarations de marine le pen
présidente du rassemblement national la
france insoumise de son côté fustige
l'exécutif pour son comportement
antidémocratique écouter eric coquerel
députés et les filles en colère
vis-à-vis monsieur castex et de ce
gouvernement savent à quoi donc les
décisions sont prises et l'assemblée
devrait accepter en quelques heures un
texte de cette importance sans moufter
en pleine nuit en dehors de toute
publicité des débats parce que personne
n'écoute les débats en pleine nuit dans
un style de de marche ou crève très mon
estime que les jambes à son prêt sable à
merci et qu'on doit pouvoir les les
amenés à siéger jour et nuit etc enfin
mais c'est quoi cette histoire même son
cloche pour les républicains même si de
leur côté ils ne sont pas contre se
passe vaccinale damien abad chef de file
du groupe lr à l'assemblée nationale par
lui d'amateurisme du gouvernement
écouter c'est un camouflet pour le
gouvernement et pour la majorité vous
avez simplement 121 députés de la
majorité qui ont voté hier soir alors
qu'ils sont plus de 300 ils étaient où
les autres ils ont déserté y en a même
qui était dans l'hémicycle et qui n'ont
pas voté c'est ça qui s'est passé hier
donc oui c'est un manque de mobilisation
de troupes de la république en marche
alors que c'est un texte essentiel et
central sur lequel président n'a plus
qu'un effet un enjeu très important ça
montre course un monde qu'on et
l'amateurisme parce que moi je crois
voilà amateurs un jour amateurs toujours
bien c'est ce qu'on a vu hier soir
encore un débat politique qui ne doit
pas se mêler à la flambée épidémique
c'est ce qu'a répété durant toute cette
journée olivier véran le ministre de la
santé a annoncé près de 300 mille
nouveaux cas de contamination due kovy
19 il a rappelé l'urgence de la mise en
place de ce projet de loi prévue pour la
mi janvier le texte elle doit
normalement arriver demain au sénat si
évidemment les discussions aboutissent
alors elle c'est un coup politique de
l'opposition un besoin de davantage de
temps de réflexion sur ce texte ou un
manque de mobilisation de la majorité et
c'était justement l'objet du débat tout
à l'heure avec pierre cabaret député la
république en marge de haute-garonne et
pierre frédéric billet vert les
républicains de droite
et il s'est passé à un mauvais coup de
cette ancienne politique qui est là et
qui qui ennuie tout le monde alors
évidemment on peut s'enorgueillir
d'avoir fait un coup politique de la
part des élèves mais on peut surtout
être réaliste et se dire que ce n'est
pas un coup politique c'est un mauvais
coup pour les français et c'est un
mauvais coup pour la santé des français
moi je pense aussi que faut plutôt
positivement le chef député il faut
prendre le temps d'avoir des réflexions
commun ce n'est que les républicains ne
sont pas contre le pass vaccinale mais
il y avait une sorte de course en avant
qui poussaient un peu les choses
peut-être que la conférence des
présidents va permettre aussi d'avoir
une réflexion en commun là dessus je
pense qu'il faut prendre un petit peu de
temps ce que la tranche d'âge les lieux
où il va être comment dire exercé se
passe vaccinale et la sortie du pass
vaccination des vraies questions il ya
700 amendements je crois que j'en avais
déjà vu deux cents ce qui est très bien
mais soyons réseau d'aprr dont un peu
plus de temps je pense que même dans vos
rangs monsieur le député je crois que
certains parlementaires à tes souhaits
de voir qu'il y avait plus de temps pour
la réflexion en commun
et nouveau record de contamination de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique plus d'un
million de cas ces dernières 24 heures
aux états unis le variant omicron est
majoritaire dans le pays aujourd'hui
l'administration bynum décide de doubler
sa commande de traitement anti qu'ovide
kaiser et autorise la vaccination pour
les 12 15 ans et les enfants à risque
âgés de 5 à 11 ans grâce d'ailleurs
une rentrée scolaire particulière pour
ces élèves et leurs parents ce matin à
miami ils étaient nombreux massé devant
leur établissement scolaire à attendre
leur piqûre de la douleur parfois mais
très souvent de la bravoure sa jara 11
ans a hâte de recevoir sa dose
je veux me faire vacciner parce que
c'est beaucoup mieux et il ya moins de
risques d'attraper le coc vide et comme
je ne veux vraiment pas attraper le coc
vide donc je suis vraiment contente de
le faire
je me fais vacciner surtout pour
protéger mon père et pour faire
davantage d'activité à l'extérieur avec
le plus de gens et pour ne pas être
infecté si certains sont vaccinés
d'autres sont tout simplement tester
comme dans ce collège de seattle où
plusieurs parents sont venus accompagner
leurs enfants nous voulions juste être
en sécurité nous voulions être sûrs que
nos enfants puissent retourner à l'école
avec un test négatif nous voulions juste
faire notre part et donc nous sommes là
mais ça a pris beaucoup de temps
et ce lundi plus de sud changement de
discours total dans la ville de
sacramento où des dizaines de
manifestants ont choisi de protester
devant le capitole contre un mandat
local de vaccination des enfants dès le
mois d'octobre la californie s'est posé
en pionnière en annonçant une obligation
vaccinale contre le coc vide dans les
écoles
nous ne sommes pas contre les vaccins
mais il s'agit de choix
en amérique nous avons la possibilité de
choisir aucun gouvernement aucun juge
aucun élu aucun bureaucrates mais le
droit de nous dire ce que nous devons
faire de notre corps
à los angeles le projet s'est heurté à
de vives critiques et a dû être
repoussée à l'automne 2022 face aux
trente mille élèves non vaccinés de son
côté l'agencé américaine du médicament
autorise un rappel après cinq mois au
lieu de six auparavant pour toutes les
tranches d'âge avec plus de 4,1 millions
de jeunes de 16 ans et plus ayant reçu
un rappel après cinq mois la tendance à
l'abaissement de l'âge vaccinal semble
s'étendre
malgré l'inquiétude initiale des experts
concernant des risques d'inflammation du
muscle cardiaque
la fda autorise la dose de rappel de
pfizer biotech chez les jeunes entre 5
et 11 ans pour les enfants
immunodéprimés ou ayant reçu une
transplantation d'organes
l'administration d'une quatrième dose du
vaccin fader permettrait de multiplier
par cinq les anti corses et les
résultats des premiers essais cliniques
réalisés sur 150 bénévoles dans un
hôpital israélien une semaine après
l'injection la quatrième dose permettra
également de protéger contre les
complications graves liées aux convives
19 le gouvernement de naftali bennett a
donné son feu vert à son administration
plus de 60 ans et au personnel médical
une prouesse pour le premier ministre
israélien
les études préliminaires montrent que la
quatrième dose multiplie par 5 les
anticorps une semaine après l'injection
offrant ainsi un niveau de protection
plus élevées
la quatrième dose et sur la quatrième
dose fonctionne
de son côté la chine doit accueillir les
jeux olympiques et divers dans un mois
tout pile malgré l'augmentation des
quais la propagation du variant mikron
la chine se dit prête à accueillir la
compétition une bulle sanitaire est
d'ores et déjà prévue pour les quelques
3000 sportifs et organisateur de
l'événement les précisions de françois
disque et beach
se prendre en photo devant le compte à
rebours des jeux olympiques d'hiver
c'est la nouvelle attraction de ce
quartier commerçant de la capitale
chinoise dans moins de 31 jours pékin
accueille cette compétition
internationale un événement attendu avec
enthousiasme et impatience par les
habitants
j'ai très hâte que les jeux olympiques
commence dans un mois on en attend tous
ensemble en famille les jeux olympiques
d'hiver
je pense que participer en tant que
volontaire et très significatif et
constitue une opportunité importante et
un mois des jeux olympiques je suis très
enthousiaste car c'est un grand
événement pour le pays je suis donc très
fier et très enthousiaste et j'espère
que les jeux seront un succès un
événement à haut risque sur le plan
sanitaire car si la stratégie zéro co
vis des autorités chinoises permet pour
l'instant de limiter le nombre de cas
dans le pays à quelques centaines
l'arrivée de milliers d'athlètes et
membres de délégations étrangères
potentiellement contaminés par le
variant à mikron pourrait provoquer
l'apparition de nouveaux foyers
épidémiques mais le gouvernement l'a sur
le pays est prêt à y faire face
lang
permettre à un plus grand nombre de
personnes de participer aux sports
d'hiver tel est le sens du mouvement
olympique
nous présenterons au monde entier des
jeux olympiques grandiose de tout coeur
le monde attend la chine avec impatience
et la chine est prête mais il faut dire
que le protocole mis en place par les
organisateurs est particulièrement
strictes pour pouvoir embarquer pour
pékin les participants devront présenter
de tests pcr négatif de - 2 96 et 72
heures dans un laboratoire homologué par
la chine pour eux la quarantaine de 21
jours ne sera pas obligatoire sauf pour
les non vaccinés
les prés de 3000 sportifs journalistes
et bénévoles devront se rendre ensuite
dans une bulle sanitaires sur les trois
sites olympiques situées dans et autour
de pékin une fois à l'intérieur
interdit pour eux d'en sortir ou de
conduire pour se déplacer seul et
transport mise en place par
l'organisation seront autorisés une
distanciation social sera également de
rigueur pour s'entraîner dans les
gymnases
nous aurons une distance de sécurité
entre les installations d'entraînement
comme mesures de protection nous
imposerons également une limitation du
nombre de personnes en fonction des
besoins chaque fois que chaque
équipement sera utilisé il sera
immédiatement nettoyé et désinfecté afin
de garantir la sécurité d'utilisation
des installations
et si on sait depuis longtemps que le
public étranger ne pourra pas assister
aux compétitions pour la population
locale l'incertitude demeure à quatre
semaines du début des jeux la
billetterie n'est toujours pas ouverte
à hong kong un troisième média décide de
fermer les journalistes du site citizen
news estime qu'ils ne peuvent plus
travailler depuis l'instauration de la
loi sur la sécurité nationale votée sous
l'impulsion de pékin de nombreuses
rédactions choisi de cesser leur
activité pour éviter les poursuites
marion caudal
c'était l'un des sites d'information les
plus populaires de hong kong citizen
muse annoncé ce dimanche qu'il fermait
ses portes pour protéger ses salariés
car quelques jours plus tôt cette
journaliste d'autres médias ont été
arrêtés par les autorités
motif invoqué par ces dernières
publication séditieuse
nous faisons du journalisme avec tout
notre professionnalisme cela n'a jamais
changé nous avons toujours été les mêmes
nous maintenons ce que nous avons publié
dans le passé et ce que nous avions
publié si nous avions pu continuer ce
qui a changé ce n'est pas nous c'est
notre environnement
nous avons fait de notre mieux pour ne
violé aucune loi mais il est difficile
de connaître les contours d'application
de la loi et nous ne pouvons plus nous
sentir en sécurité pour exercer notre
métier
en quelques mois c'est le troisième
média indépendant de l'ex territoire
britannique qui se met à l'arrêt depuis
l'adoption de la loi sur la sécurité
nationale en 2020 la presse indépendante
se plaint de difficultés croissantes
pour travailler
des fermetures qui font l'objet de
critiques notamment de la part des
médias occidentaux et auquel la
dirigeante de hong kong oppose une fin
de non recevoir
selon carrie l'âme la fermeture des
médias ne peut pas être associée à la
loi sur la sécurité nationale
ce matin j'ai eu des informations selon
lesquelles en raison de la fermeture des
médias en ligne
liberté de la presse à hong kong risque
de s'éteindre ou que la presse libre de
hong kong risque de s'effondrer je ne
peux tout simplement pas accepter ce
genre d'allégations mais rien n'est plus
important que l'état de droit à hong
kong comme chacun de nous les
journalistes et les organisations du
média doivent respecter et se conformer
à la loi s'ils craignent de ne pas
pouvoir se conformer à la loi alors ils
doivent prendre des décisions en
conséquence
[Musique]
l'ex colonie britannique a longtemps été
considéré comme un bastion de la liberté
de la presse en asie mais en raison du
vote de la loi sur la sécurité nationale
et de ces fermetures récentes les rares
plateformes que compte encore en kong
craignent désormais pour leur avenir
dalé 2021 a vu exploser le nombre de
migrants tentant de traverser la manche
à plus de 28000 c'est un record le
triple par rapport à 2020 un casse tête
donc pour les politiques pour les
autorités britanniques mais aussi
françaises elles souffrent de tensions
grandissantes entre londres et paris est
les détails en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et triste record également en espagne
selon les ong camille nendo fronteras
plus de 4400 migrants elles sont morts
ou disparus en mer en 2021 en provenance
du nord-ouest de l'afrique pour la
majorité il tentait de rejoindre les
canaris chez les corps de la plupart
d'entre eux n'ont jamais été retrouvés
l'espagne est l'une des principales
portes d'entrée des migrants en europe
à près de 37 mille quatre cents migrants
sont arrivés sur ses côtes en 2021 à des
chiffres du ministère espagnol de
l'intérieur
deux jours après la démission du premier
ministre de nouvelles manifestations ont
éclaté aujourd'hui dans la capitale du
soudan contre le pouvoir militaire en
place les forces de l'ordre se sont
déployées sur place et ont utilisé des
gaz lacrymogènes pour tenter de
disperser la foule le soudan qui connaît
un contexte politique tendu ces derniers
temps depuis le coup d'état du mois
d'octobre dernier 57 personnes ont été
tuées par balles lors des manifestations
walid bennani
loin d'être un long fleuve tranquille
dans les rues de khartoum la démission
du premier ministre abdallah amdocs deux
jours plus tôt ne semble pas avoir
apaisé les craintes bien au contraire
après sa démission nous avons le
sentiment que le soudan a perdu une
personnalité importante qui était
approuvé par la communauté
internationale et le peuple soudanais
nous espérons qu'il reviendra dans la
période à venir en tant qu'indépendant
et deviendra le président soudanais
amdocs a envoyé un message à tous les
politiciens soudanais essaie de se
retirer si quelqu'un ne peut pas assumer
une tâche c'est la meilleure leçon il
n'est jamais arrivé dans l'histoire du
soudan qu'une personne se présente et
admettre franchement sa défaite devant
le peuple
elle l'attitude du désormais ex premiers
ministres questionné depuis le 21
novembre date de son retour politique
après avoir passé un mois en résidence
surveillée et mise à l'écart liées à
l'or aux conséquences du coup militaire
du général al borhane une figure
importante de l'ancien gouvernement
déchu d'omar el béchir le général al
burhan avait annulé en octobre
l'alternance militaire civil pour bien
aboutir à des élections libres en 2023
lorsque j'ai accepté la mission de
premier ministre de transition
je savais parfaitement que la route
n'était pas pavé de roses je savais que
la route était difficile et n'allez pas
en ligne droite mais avec la volonté et
l'action conjointe nous pouvons amener
notre pays à la sécurité
je ne me lasserai pas de répéter que
nous devons nous mettre d'accord sur la
manière dont le soudan est gouvernée et
laisser le choix de la manière dont le
soudan est gouverné au grand peuple
soudanais par contre sous van der sar
blason
dimanche abdallah mme diop a donc posé
sa démission regrettant de ne pas avoir
rassemblé toutes les forces politiques
et de ne pouvoir éviter surtout les
effusions de sang dans les rues depuis
deux mois les manifestations contre et
pour l'armée se succèdent chaque semaine
les connexions internet et téléphoniques
sont brouillées les forces de sécurité
ont accentué les fouilles dans les
maisons et bâtiments le pays est divisé
la communauté internationale s'inquiète
je regrette la décision de monsieur
amdocs mais la respecte les auteurs de
violences au cours de ces derniers mois
doivent être traduits en justice le
soudan a besoin d'un dialogue inclusif
sur la façon de réaliser son avenir
démocratique et pacifique
lundi soir via un communiqué des forces
armées le général al burhan souligné
l'importance de former un gouvernement
indépendant avec des tâches spécifiques
la turquie est au bord de la crise
économique et financière à l'inflation
bat des records sur injection du
président turc erdogan à la banque
centrale pourtant indépendantes
continuent de baisser ses taux
directeurs au nom de l'indépendance
économique du pays sandra tshiongo
c'est dans les supermarchés ou dans les
foires comme celle ci en carats que les
effets de l'inflation sont notables
selon les chiffres officiels les prix de
la farine et du poulet ont augmenté de
86 % en un an l'huile de tournesol de
76% et le pain de 54 % ce qui représente
une hausse globale de près de 44 % des
prix à la consommation sur un an
l'opposition et une partie de la
population accuse l'office national des
statistiques de sous-estimer la hausse
je ne veux pas dépenser beaucoup
d'argent cette année vu la situation
économique actuelle je dépenserai 200
livres maximum si j'achète quelque chose
ce sera pour mes enfants nous avons du
fromage nous avons des biscuits nous
avons des olives nous avons des
saucisses elle coûte environ 600 livres
par rapport à l'année dernière c'est
extrêmement cher il y a quelques
semaines le gouvernement a demandé aux
grandes chaînes de supermarchés de
revoir leurs prix à la baisse un appel
resté sans réponse
notre chiffre d'affaires a baissé de -
40 % par rapport à avant l'épidémie en
tant que chef d'entreprise j'ai
l'impression par exemple que les années
précédentes nous pouvions récupérer la
location de nos stands au cours des cinq
premiers jours d'une foire comme celle
ci aujourd'hui nos ventes ne couvre pas
nos charges autre signe de l'inflation
en turquie la grogne des chauffeurs de
taxi le gouvernement augmenter au 1er
janvier dernier de 10 centimes le prix
de départ des courses
j'attends ici depuis trois heures je
dois encore attendre deux heures un
poste de péage fonctionne il est une
augmentation de 100% du prix du péage
une augmentation de 100 % du carburant
mais nos prix ont augmenté de 36% nous
ne savons pas quoi faire les citoyens
ont raison nous avons raison dans ce
contexte recep tayyip erdogan a augmenté
le salaire minimum de 50 % au 1er
janvier dernier il atteint désormais
environ 275 euros ce lundi le chef
d'état turc a défendu ses résultats
avant d'accuser une élite de profiter de
la situation
alors que la nation perdre et que les
citoyens retraités les fonctionnaires
les travailleurs les entrepreneurs les
commerçants et les producteurs perdent
et cette minorité d'élite qui a profité
des crises a continué à gagner à
prospérer et accroître sa richesse
le gouverneur de la banque centrale a
changé de nombreuses fois pendant cette
crise recep tayyip erdogan a également
remplacé à trois reprises son ministre
des finances depuis 2018 la dernière
fois c'était le 2 décembre en pleine
débâcle
et on termine ce journal avec notre
rubrique alerter sur le web une
sélection d'articles à retrouver sur
notre site arte france point tv fia et
la meuse contexte du classement des plus
grandes fortunes du monde classement
publié par l' indice bloober billionaire
les personnalités dans le top 10 sont
engagés à 402 milliards de dollars en
2021 est jeff bezos c'est bernard
arnault figure sur le podium
respectivement à la deuxième et
troisième place
un grand leader respecté de tous donald
trump apporte son soutien à viktor orban
vue des prochaines législatives
elle le premier ministre hongrois qui
avait été reçu à la maison blanche par
l'ancien président américain dont le
soutien a provoqué une série de
critiques de la part du camp démocrate a
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans un peu plus de trente
minutes restez avec nous sur arte france
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la